[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever
today we got cat hello we got soy
what's up we got casey hi chan
don't forget that name tomas thomas yep
we got bartholomew quan
bartholomew we got joe jitsukawa joe h
jitsukawa
h it's actually m it's h
for herbert herbert my favorite
character on family guy herbert the
pervert
i'm surprised he's not canceled why what
do you do
he's a pervert that's it he's a
pedophile
cartoons do get away with a lot of [ __ ]
yeah dude south park how are they not
canceled yeah
i love that they try to cancel south
park a while ago i think they always
tried to
yeah republicans tried to in the 90s and
they failed
yeah and then now the liberals are
trying to yeah so it's just going to pay
for everything
yeah how come people are going after
simpsons out of all i mean they're not
right it's a race thing not just the poo
but the
the hairdresser guy too i guess
hairdresser guy it's basically all the
hank azaria characters he's the he's the
gay hairdresser
oh they just don't like hank his area
well no he said he's
he so he's not any of those any of those
things so then
yeah they they replaced him so if you're
not gay they don't want you
to pretend gay right i see i see
so the bird cage with robin williams
could not happen true
you would think that scar johansen as an
asian character
i thought she was going to happen either
it should have happened
it did it did a glitch in the show yeah
i thought she was representing pretty
good but
someone told me she's not asian well the
creators came out and said that it
didn't even matter because
her character is an ai so it doesn't
have to be asian
it's just that like people associate
anime with being asian
so they're like oh she has to be like an
asian woman she's like an asian woman
that's because they fetishized her as an
asian woman
yeah see it's all bad everything's bad
that's crazy don't think it no hey so
did you get
more followers after you came on our
show
yeah i did and i will say i think it's
really funny because i
think you're the one who dm'd me and you
said uh something along the lines send
me news
[Laughter]
imagine if i did that to all the girls
after the show i meet him
send nudes i would say noodles
i would say noodles i would send you
noodles
the subject line is now and then it's
sad news
now said news but you were telling me
that uh you have to
give certain like people heads up when
they come on the show because you're
like oh like people are gonna
like roast you if they don't like you
and in my head i was like sir
i am from the comedy world there is
nothing
and nobody in this world that can hurt
my feelings because we already share the
same fans
exactly exactly good job i have skin
of [ __ ] what's thick teflon not that
thick i
cut through it all the time with my
knife when i want to cut my chicken
they you're cooking pans with that okay
not teflon
i have a skin of steel at this point
steel they make a lot of things out of
steel yeah i cry secretly at night
yeah so that's more accurate yeah you've
been in a fragile place i'm sorry how
about you so do you get
food haters me not really do you cry at
night
uh no but i mean my audience is like
pretty positive and like
usually if someone writes something mean
it's usually about weight well get ready
because we got some [ __ ] up fans
yeah we have wonderful ones too by the
way that will support your only fans if
you have one
but um they are yeah yeah i feel like it
they wouldn't be bad well if they are
like usually my followers just take care
of it
sometimes i like pin i hate hate comment
i'm just like whatever i'm just going to
put it
i just think it's like the biggest like
you wanted attention i gave you
attention yeah and now you're i'm gonna
pin it
and then that's like putting them on a
[ __ ] hook and throwing me in the
ocean this guy was like talking about
what he's like oh i i just care about
you like you need to like stop eating so
much
and then i put them in my story and then
i pinned it and next thing you know like
he like
deleted it and he left me like a long
mean comment about you're so
childish like i was just trying to help
you and you had all your friend fans
attack me and i was like he's like
i called you fat [ __ ] i was just trying
to help you he's like let me try to call
you childish to reach you
yeah and i was like i didn't i didn't do
anything like you you wrote the comment
all i did was just pinned it and then
people attacked you because you know i
didn't agree
that's a power move pinning i hate
comments see i always thought that
people on um our our fans are like they
all want to be funny right
so then they'll talk [ __ ] so they could
get attention because that's what
usually
happens they just talk [ __ ] and then
they're like oh my god i'm your biggest
fan thank you for
noticing me you got to stop like letting
it bother you really yeah
absolutely no the jk fans are the best
they are though dude to be hon like we
talk a lot of [ __ ] because it's like
hella funny we're not talking about the
fans though we're talking about
the haters who are super fans i think
our haters are
really yeah super fast super fans i hate
you like we own their brains and like we
operate their [ __ ] brains
like they can't click away no yeah like
they
have to watch every single video they're
hella like that's why i'm like
dude they love us as much as they don't
want to admit it yeah
like they're so irrelevant i can't even
believe how irrelevant they are that's
why i'm talking about them non-stop
they support you almost as like even
more than your fans do who love you
yeah more than my wife supports me
these people support me they're like
there before the they even play the
video they hit the dislike button
yeah that's a they're waiting for your
video to go up there
they're f5 and the [ __ ] out of their
keyboard yeah
it's great but they're awesome but yeah
i have to warn
the women just like even on my instagram
or like anybody that
comes around because there are hella
weird people
that will look follow them dm them and
say hey are you [ __ ] joe
right wow oh yeah that's that's the
question
all the time too with uh all the men
that i work with and
just because i'm the only girl there
they see my [ __ ] literally everywhere
of course
they imagine [ __ ] yeah they're just
like how many of the guys have you
[ __ ]
and will you [ __ ] me after yeah they're
like oh my god you definitely did this
and this like i hope you're not booking
me though oh i'm not [ __ ] okay thank
you i'm just
hockey shaming in the workplace thank
you you gotta separate it okay
on your own time yeah glaze it at home
that's right
if you want to get glazed like a donut
that's for that's for that's a crispy
cream
personal life damn that's crazy it is
man and then it's just
how do you balance that right because
it's like we do have
uh females that come on the show and
like that are around them don't [ __ ] you
and a lot of them don't
they think that they think that a lot of
them but they think that every one of
them you know that's what's so funny
about it
you're like the jk sexy and it's so
horrible
yeah like that's a bad image i know
right
they just don't have any other choices
how can you shed the skin
why do they want to know that though
like what's the point i think
people live vicariously through others
right
and then like i don't know if you guys
have heard this before but it like those
guys would be like hey bro like [ __ ] her
for me
like they'll say stuff like that right
which bros do yeah
but like if people know each other it
makes sense it makes sense right let's
say both me and casey are single in
college
like we'll egg each other on and stuff
like that right but someone that doesn't
even know who the [ __ ] you are
or you don't know who the [ __ ] they are
what makes them think if
okay if i asked joe if i only asked joe
if he [ __ ] her or not
he owes me this response you know what i
mean it's so [ __ ] weird
tell me bro you [ __ ] her and then
joe's like
who the [ __ ] are you get the [ __ ] away
from me it's so weird that they
uh whoever is writing these weird dm's
automatically assume there is a response
to it like there's no boundary
yeah that's weird but well it depends
because if you're my friend like bart
tells me all the time you say hey [ __ ]
[ __ ] for me i'm like
i got you tonight
i understand but if you don't even know
each other like it's so weird
no they'll be full-on debates of like
you know whether it's my comments or
in you know jk of like oh
you know joe's definitely [ __ ]
tagging that whatever whatever
and then they'll be like no she's way
too [ __ ] good he'll never bag a girl
like that
and then someone else will come in like
but he's got money though and then like
that's different that's a different
and i'm like dude that is crazy like
why is it so meaningful that i [ __ ]
somebody
yeah well it's interesting it is
it is it is i like hearing about who
you're [ __ ] yeah but i tell you as a
friend and you know the deep dark
secrets and it's fun i do it's very yeah
i guess the closest thing i can relate
to is like following like fighter
narratives right like leading up to a
big fight
oh this person did this person did this
and they're like wondering like oh if
this person
did this you know but i never actually
like dm
conor mcgregor like hey did you really
throw that chair at the bus because i
know he's just not going to reply to me
so it's just weird when you don't know
yeah she's so [ __ ]
weird it takes a certain type of person
maybe they watch so many videos
that they really think that you you're
you're yeah you're really a friend
but you will dm brandon shop [ __ ] you
dude
did you guys talk about that at all no i
totally forgot about that i should tell
him i still have it i didn't yeah did
you
did you unsend the phone number i never
understood anything
if he looked in his dm's
what up guys this episode is brought to
you by fields
fields is a premium cbd brand that comes
directly to your door and it helps with
all kinds of things like anxiety
nervousness sleeplessness and what's
really cool about it there's
zero hangover the next day and there's
no addiction
whatsoever and it naturally does all
those things yep
and i use fields to chill me the hell
out
because i didn't realize that i am very
caffeine sensitive
and it might work for different peoples
in different ways
but for me specifically when i drink a
little bit too much coffee or too late
in the day or something
yeah this is what happened is i took a
nap woke up
it was like 4 p.m but i was like i need
a little bit of that booster oh you're
getting stuff done oh yeah
and i drink a coffee but coffee is so
tasty
yeah and i drink another one and i drink
like maybe about five cups
oh [ __ ] and i was like whoa whoa whoa
whoa what i try to work out and i try to
do
other things to chill me out but like i
was in bed
like going like this every three seconds
like oh damn what the [ __ ] man
like i'm like you know when you're in
bed and you have so much anxiety that
you start contemplating about
your past present and future at the same
time yeah that's what was happening to
me and i said
what the [ __ ] and i got the blankets off
of me and
i decided yo thank you feels for sending
me
a couple of these beautiful droplets
because i put that in my mouth and i
said
let me just sit here and meditate chill
out a little bit
reduce my heart rate and i started to
calm the hell down did you put five
drops to balance the five cups
i probably just put a squirt in there
right yeah and
um you know i was listening to some
chill podcast stuff
relaxing you know stroke myself
out and i went to sleep yeah and i woke
up the next day and i was like
dude that was i went through a roller
coaster experience
yeah that was crazy that's what's dope
about feels it does help with anxiety it
does help with sleepiness and stuff like
that and this is
and if this is your first time they
actually have a hotline that you can
call
and they can help you out they can walk
you through it like how many drops do i
take
i've never tried this thing before and
they can make you feel comfortable so
you don't feel like you're going into
this
alone which is super cool and right now
for all of our listeners you can get 50
off plus free shipping just go to
feels.com
off the record that's feels f e a l s
dot com slash
off the record to get 50 percent off
plus free shipping
check it out bye-bye i will say people
don't know this about joe
but he has had so many opportunities
that he has not
like hit on that i'm kind of i'm kind of
impressed and proud of you dude
why why because because people probably
think that i [ __ ] everything that i want
they actually think yeah yeah
but you're a man of quality that's not
the man and and there's
beautiful women that i also uh i don't
want to say deny
i've seen him turned up i'll say it for
you yeah i've seen him turn on beautiful
woman
beautiful okay all right you're letting
so many that is
that's way beyond my people wouldn't
even believe the names that i would drop
here
but they have that who have expressed
interest on this
i don't even believe the name through
his friend steve and this man [ __ ]
no no no no no he just goes no no no to
them
and i get it's not the brand that's all
you know what it is though it's because
the way that i am on camera and how i
play and whatever
is different from real life yeah real
life
is my romance yeah my standards are
so low yeah in real life i'm just
kidding
i was like wait that took a turn
no no um i i think that uh i talk a lot
about
my personal life here that people think
that i'm always a hundred percent
but there's a little bit of sprinkling
in of um trolling and funny
stuff right well there's some more
there's more heart than horny than
people think
heart than horny yeah a little more
heart than horny i think but you're very
horny i'm not i am very horny but yes
there's the heart part that i don't talk
about online yeah yeah yeah
like for example if i do like somebody
i won't have casual sex because i don't
want to
taint whatever i have going on at that
moment
but you'll look in the eyes and say
listen i'm
very horny
has he said these things to you yeah
yeah yeah
i don't know like is he hitting on you
no you're saying it almost as if he
looked at you
lovingly
you have to understand i'm very horny
like close-up shot one tear falls down
his tree doesn't mean he's gonna yeah
i'm just like i like her so much i just
i'm so horny but
gee i can't get myself to doing it
because if he gives it away like that
yeah
it can't be long term yes so you're not
a hussy is what you're saying yeah
no there's nothing wrong with how season
we love them you don't try to test it
you don't try like okay i like this girl
but let me bang a couple of other ones
just to make sure
i really like this well what i've
learned is that
when you unlock that door you
destroy the uh you kind of taint
the uh psychological perception of
this person because now um
she's not as i don't wanna i don't know
how other
way to say this but like valuable in
your mind because
it can be rep her affection can be
replaced by other things
but it's kind of like biohacking
yourself a little bit
it's like climbing k2 before everest
you're never going back to k2
dude it's all about everest after that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you know
and then also it's about the the whole
reason why it's so good is because you
have the same
like it's special right and then once
you do share
that with someone else then it no longer
has that same type of weight bart
doesn't get it because he has no [ __ ]
game
he's been in a marriage for like i mean
he's been with somebody for 10 years and
he doesn't get this [ __ ]
so for example
my mentality of when i don't like
anybody
it's free game so i don't have my heart
or eyes set on anyone so it's like
yeah i'm single let's have fun right but
once i do like someone then everything
else just kind of feels
secondary or like a temporary relief but
it's not what i wanted
it's like i was i was craving a steak
but i got noodles instead and i like
noodles and it made me full but then
[ __ ] now it just kind of ruined the
whole thing yeah yeah yeah ruined your
meal
it ruined my meal now i don't want to
eat the steak anymore but that's what i
wanted and and i
and i feel bad yeah yeah i don't know
that makes sense no it does make
of sense well like bart's only [ __ ]
like one person in the last 10 years
right yeah and i [ __ ] two people left
sitting here so i like i have
i'm like me too before my current
relationship i was with a guy
since i was 14 to 24. oh cereal monogamy
14
to 24. like my high school sweetheart i
thought
like almost 10 years like basically uh i
rounded up to 10. but so you had like a
hometown
yeah he was like my high school
sweetheart i was gonna
in my head i was gonna be with him for
the rest of my life he went straight to
porn star
uh yeah but i didn't want yeah yeah i
did
i did i absolutely did but this porn
star is like a stripper with a heart of
gold you know
yeah that's pretty cool is that what all
girls want that's what all strippers are
actually
if you actually look deeper so you were
with them for a decade and then all of a
sudden you find
you got with this other guy i didn't
know uh my current boyfriend i hadn't
known
um me and my ex are together from high
school up until i came to la and it was
one of those things where
he was in the bay area we're both from
san jose and i moved to la and i knew my
career was going to be here
and he was in a place in his life where
he was trying to figure out what he was
going to do
so he decided to move to la and be with
me while he tried to figure it out
l.a is not for him he kind of like gave
up
what he wanted and like what he wanted
to do in his life
to be with me and it ended up just like
souring that whole relationship because
then there's resentment of like
well i dropped everything for you to be
with you but i'm not happy here
and then i'm not happy that he's
resenting me for something i didn't ask
him to do
yeah he couldn't find his industry here
in l.a i
just think he's here it's not
necessarily industry i think he just
wanted to be
back where we were from like he loves
the bay area he doesn't like la it was
just more of a location thing
probably mine's that thing he's already
coming into it like i don't want to live
here
very simply yeah kind of sounds like a
little bit yeah a little bit
and then so you never had a whole face i
had a very short whole face because i
he and i broke up uh winter like right
before the pandemic
and then he was like still living with
me because we had like that quarantine
when we thought was just gonna last two
weeks
after that it lasted like a month and
he's like i'm gonna go back to the bay
i'll slowly start to move my stuff out
once he left i had a whole face for like
six months and then i met my current
boyfriend
and between that time i only [ __ ] like
maybe like two people
but that's a whole face for you but yeah
that's just because like i would like
you might have a lower body account than
me really yeah i think i [ __ ] like
eight people max
i [ __ ] four people [ __ ] yeah i'm so
glad to meet you
finally i feel i feel good but she's 25
though just wait just wait what does
that mean
he's saying i'm going to break up with
my if you do
i heard it too i heard it too sorry
because i'm sending him nudes
for 30 days i hope you stay together and
happily ever after right
but if you do which statistics say
percentages are high well-handled right
i believe
that especially like uh if we speak
stereotypically
right asian women in their 20s don't
stereotypically um go through many
partners until their late 20s yes
absolutely because there's a lot of
traditional like shame and culture and
yeah expectations of being a lady yeah
but you being in this industry and like
being more open now and like whatever
meeting all these people
i think like you're more you're probably
more sexually liberated right like
you're with this
uh porn star now whatever and she's got
a feed pick empire
yeah so like your approach to it will
probably be
way more confident than you were in your
early 20s i'm assuming i think because i
was with him for so long
and he was like my consistent like only
partner for those
parts of my life i was so confident
sexually already and like mentally i
knew what i wanted i knew i
just wanted to hook up with like one or
two guys like i have them in rotation
depending on who i wanted to see
like i be their feedback to me was that
i was very
cold when i didn't want them and they
were expecting me to
because i was coming out of a
relationship to be like oh she's gonna
catch feelings for me eventually
oh but they're like you're not sprung on
me yeah they're like
why are you texting me why don't you
want to hang out and i was like i
i just i this isn't what i want i told
you i want
when my wife was doing the whole face
she had the same problem like nikki
everyone knows
but um she had the same problem guys
would do the attachment thing and she
was like no this is just sex [ __ ]
and then they would all be all the
tables have time
so empowering that's like super
empowering yeah and then i met my
boyfriend and now like
i i feel like i i love being in a
relationship i love being monogamous i
love having like that one person i can
like come home to and
be completely comfortable with i think
the moment i got into this relationship
i just like
shed all that like cold whole face out
of me
so do you think that was like a defense
uh yeah because i know i'm very i become
attached to people very quickly whether
it's friendship
romantic relationships like co-workers
i'm just i i'm very nurturing
so if i don't keep you at a distance i
know i will potentially
fall for you and then hurt myself so
that's why i don't text you unless i
want dick
i need the structure because i have so
much [ __ ] games coming on my
fingertips
oh yeah you ooh sexy i'm like this
[ __ ] i'm like this [ __ ]
chump yeah one relationship in 10 years
you know
[ __ ] up ah [ __ ] up dude we did
we did a we did a whole pickup game
yesterday on just kidding party
right on geo right he was the first to
get eliminated and he's
he sued his own [ __ ] wife while
picking her up dude
that's how he got her number he got her
number by suing her
i don't believe you how do i watch this
you gotta watch i gotta watch it on
patreon
and that it was one of the most funniest
[ __ ] jk parties
it's the ultimate game yeah he got her
number by [ __ ]
she didn't even choose her old husband
dude isn't that how he got with geo to
be
[ __ ] pretty much dude he's in if he
didn't look like this he would be
textbook in cell you know what i'm
saying
that's why you work so hard to maintain
it
[Music]
you